I think she said bag piping yeah
probably sounded dirty but it wasn't no
no no I think it is dirty yeah yeah yeah
yeah nobody screams out have you heard
of bagpiping unless it's gross
because
something to do with a nut sack TV now
tea bag I know what this is the tea bag
so bagpipe implies you gotta make a
weird noise
are you giving somebody's nut sack like
a raspberry like what is that on your
raspberry no giving like you know how
you know what a raspberry is yeah like
on somebody's nut sack like a bagpipe oh
like yeah
yeah
that was my guess that sounds terrible
but it sounds awful well listen
um
don't leave us all in suspense
yeah what is it wait does it have
anything to do with Dijon mustard
I was and really hoping tell me what it
is
huh
BYU wait a second listen up go ahead
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait we're only
halfway there oh God everybody shut up
hold on dude this is Jessica everybody's
still having sex with an armpit
what's it so you make that noise and
then the the dog makes noises
I think it should be called tromboning
yeah but it looks like it would feel
like grating cheese like it looks it
sounds like it would be painful
uh
because then it's it could be called the
cheese grater yeah that's what I'm
saying
okay wow that is not a question I was
expecting
yeah
nope okay at all